TREVOR JOHNS: --couldn't play
a video as an Android
application.
Of course, you already mentioned
one of them, which
is to go ahead and open up the
native YouTube application.
You can do that via an intent.
And that's definitely a good
approach, but the downside
there is that it's going
to take you out of your
application.
And so if you're looking for a
more immersive experience, you
have a few other options.
You could go ahead and ad a web
view which links to the
Flash version of YouTube.
Or you could also go
and low the HTML
file version of YouTube.
Each of those have
some catches,
though, pretty important.
Older devices-- and actually
some newer devices for that
matter, too--
don't have Flash installed.
So the Flash Player's not
always available.
And older devices aren't going
to be able to play HTML5 file
video unless they have an
HTML5-compliant WebView
implementation.
So with that out of the way,
for current devices, that
pretty much limits
your options to
built-in YouTube app.
So for almost all practical
purposes right now, I'd say
the best option is to go ahead
and fire it off an intent and
send the user off to the YouTube
player just so they
have the best YouTube
playback experience.
Now that said, we did
pre-announce a YouTube API for
Android at Google
I/O this year.
It's not ready yet, but
it will be at some
point in the future.
And that will allow you to go
ahead and embed YouTube videos
within your application,
just as a--
basically the way WebView works
except it will be a
YouTube view.
So if you want to learn more
about that, go ahead and
search Google for YouTube
Android API.
And there's a slide
deck and a--
actually a video on YouTube for
that matter, where you can
go ahead and learn more
about all of that.
And keep an eye on that
for some time
later in the near future.
Don't know an exact date, but
sometime hopefully soon, there
will be some more
news on that.
And if you want a demo,
actually, the Google I/O app,
the Android schedule
app is a good
example of how that works.
ALEX LUCAS: Here is actually
an interesting question.
I don't know the answer to
this myself, but is it
possible to detect at run time
if the phone will support
YouTube via Flash?
TREVOR JOHNS: Oh, that's
a good question.
I imagine you could actually
check PackageManager and look
for the Flash package.
And if you see that on there,
It's probably a pretty good
sign Flash is working.
ALEX LUCAS: Right.
See what I would suggest maybe
is, because the post from
Michelle does state that she
would prefer to keep the user
inside the app, is if there's a
way to detect at run time if
Flash is supported on the device
or if YouTube via HTML5
would be supported on
the device, it would
require extra effort.
But you could just do all three
implementations and say,
OK, if Flash is supported on
this device, do it in Flash.
If not, if HTML5 is supported
on this device,
do an embedded WebView.
If not, intent out.
That way you would have a wider
range of phones that you
support for in-app and not
necessarily have to go to the
YouTube app every time.
TREVOR JOHNS: Yeah.
Now, I've seen some people use
RTSP also, but I'm not sure if
that's actually allowed.
So you might want to check the
YouTube terms of service.
I sort of a suspicion that
you might not be
allowed to do that.
ALEX LUCAS: We discourage
sketchy behavior.
TREVOR JOHNS: Right.
ALEX LUCAS: Ethical and TOS
issues aside, even though they
are real issues.
But if you do something like
that, it is liable to get
broken in the next version of
Android once a security fix
for that is determined.
TREVOR JOHNS: I don't think
that's a security issue.
ALEX LUCAS: Not security,
but--
TREVOR JOHNS: I think that's
just a YouTube terms of
service issue.
But in any case, I think the
correct answer here until we
get the YouTube API
out is to go
ahead and use the embedded--
the native YouTube app.
I think for pretty much every
case there, you're going to
get the best experience
that way.
At least for now.
So let's go ahead and move
on to the next question.
I just realized, Dan, we never
turn on the lights in here.
ALEX LUCAS: Makes
us look like--
DAN: We can make that happen.
TREVOR JOHNS: Yeah, all right.
Let's move on to the
next question.
ALEX LUCAS: All right, the
next question. "A real
Bluetooth headset button push
still works in the foreground
music app, but my mimicked
action_media_button intents no
longer work in Android
4.0 or above.
As I said, Google
music hogs them.
What are Bluetooth headsets
doing differently?"
TREVOR JOHNS: Excellent
question.
So this question, I think, just
came in probably about 10
minutes before our broadcast.
ALEX LUCAS: Yeah, we,
unfortunately, have not had
time to research it, and neither
of us, I think, know
off the top of our heads.
TREVOR JOHNS: Yeah.
It's possible that
it's being--
the media framework is going
in and integrating directly
with the Bluetooth stack.
I'm not actually sure.
The good news is the source
is out there.
If you want to go ahead and take
a look, you can go ahead
and dig into it a
little deeper.
We'll do the same on our end and
try and get you an answer
for the next show.
Again, we just don't
have enough time.
We didn't have enough time
before to actually get
researching an answer here.
I think trying to mimic the
action_media_button intent to
simulate a Bluetooth button push
is a little sketchy, so
I'm not terribly surprised
that you're
having some issues there.
But we'll try and get you an
answer, try and figure out
what's going on.
Join us next week and we'll have
an answer for you at the
beginning of the show.
ALEX LUCAS: We just
got brighter.
TREVOR JOHNS: It did.
ALEX LUCAS: Yeah.
TREVOR JOHNS: All right.
ALEX LUCAS: It takes
away my ominous,
shadowy appearance, though.
TREVOR JOHNS: All right.
So, "is there a reason why
Google does not release
updates of new Android versions
for all interested
developers with Nexus 7 and the
Galaxy Nexus devices right
away outside of the long OTA
cycle without having to root
the device and doing
it manually?"
ALEX LUCAS: Yes.
Next question.
TREVOR JOHNS: And that's
by Chris from London.
Oh, I think it's actually
a valid point.
ALEX LUCAS: I was joking.
TREVOR JOHNS: So right now,
the way we do software
updates, assuming you have a
device that has an OS update
available, is we roll the device
out to a fraction of
users at a time.
And there's a number of
reasons we do that.
First off, it makes sure that
we don't overload carrier
networks for people who are
on cellular connections.
In fact, I think there's even an
option in there where they
can go and offer only to
Wi-Fi users for the
first 24, 48 hours.
But we also go and roll out
slowly just to make sure if
there's any bugs with update,
major, major bugs that somehow
we didn't catch during testing,
That way we can go
ahead and abort the update and
solve those problems before
many users are impacted.
Now, we do test things pretty
thoroughly, and it's rare that
something like that happens.
It's just a safety device that
we've basically built in.
I think in the case
of developers,
it's a valid concern.
It would be definitely very nice
to be one of the first
users to get a software update,
so that way you can
update your application.
So I'll make sure that the--
actually, I think that we
already filed a bug this
morning for this.
So there is a bug open.
We'll go ahead and make sure
that the OTA team sees it as a
feature request.
I think it's completely
valid, and thank you
for the great idea.
We'll see we can do to get
that implemented for you.
ALEX LUCAS: Yeah.
TREVOR JOHNS: All right.
ALEX LUCAS: OK.
"When will we get a supported
Marketplace API, eg, to search
the marketplace for apps
and pull their details,
screenshots, and analyze
comments and ratings?
Microsoft and Apple support
this, and they are closed
markets."
That's a good question.
Unfortunately, this definitely
falls into the category of
roadmap question.
And as a matter of policy, we
can't discuss future features
that we may or may not be
implementing or whether or not
we're working on them, when the
hypothetical release day
would be, that kind of thing.
We will definitely file it
as a feature request.
But we can't really say anything
about when it would
happen, or if we're
working on it.
TREVOR JOHNS: Yep.
I think that's a pretty
good answer.
So Percy from the Philippines
says, "can I retrieve data
from the Google Maps API
so I can use it for my
location-based service
application I'm developing/"
So I'm not sure what sort of
data you're looking for Percy,
but there are a number
of things that
you can access already.
You can access the user's
current location via the
location manager.
And that actually really doesn't
have anything to do
with Google Maps.
It's just what's the user's
latitude, longitude, altitude,
basic data you'd get from GPS.
Or if there's a Wi-Fi network
nearby, it can do course
location, things like that.
You can also do geocoding which
is-- actually I think
it's reverse geocoding.
Is it?
No.
It's standard geocoding.
Yeah.
It's converting latitude
and longitude to a
human-readable address.
ALEX LUCAS: That's reverse
geocoding.
TREVOR JOHNS: OK.
Now, do we--
I think we support both
ways, don't we?
ALEX LUCAS: I believe we
support both ways.
Those actually might be
via the Maps API.
TREVOR JOHNS: Actually
it's not.
It's via LocationManager.
ALEX LUCAS: Interesting.
TREVOR JOHNS: I think it uses
Maps under the hood.
But it is part of the
LocationManager package.
So there's utilities to go and
convert from lat/long to an
address and back from
address to lat/long.
So that's all totally
possible.
Now if you want to do something
more graphical, right?
You want to display a map and
let the user see where they
are in the world as opposed
to just telling them their
numerical address, right?
You can embed MapView inside of
your application which will
render Google Maps, the
user's location.
And there's some limited
options to go
and customize that.
If you want to go a step further
and start adding
really complicated stuff
like polygons--
ALEX LUCAS: Markers.
TREVOR JOHNS: --markers, custom
map tiles, you could go
ahead and add a WebView that
loads the Google Maps
API from the web.
And that's how you
can get some of
those advanced features.
We definitely encourage
people to use a
standard MapView at first.
But sometimes you want to do
these advanced things, and
that's when you have to look
into the web-based APIs.
So I think that's a
yes as far as the
answer to this question.
ALEX LUCAS: Yeah.
TREVOR JOHNS: Now if you want
to do something like get
driving directions, though,
that's where you're going to
run into some problems.
And you won't be able to pull
that data out of Google Maps.
But I believe you can send the
user-- yeah, you can totally
just send the user over to
Google Maps and construct a
URL for directions and
have that load.
So there are ways to go and
tell Google Maps what data
you'd like it to display.
But it'll still be within Google
Maps for the users
receiving that content.
ALEX LUCAS: Yeah.
I I also want to add, we do have
a lot of online resources
for using the Maps API.
With Android, it's on
developer.android.com/android.
I don't remember the tail
end of that URL.
TREVOR JOHNS: Wait,
developer.android.com/android?
ALEX LUCAS: Oh, sorry,
developer.google.com/android.
TREVOR JOHNS: There you go.
ALEX LUCAS: And that's where
most of the APIs for using
Google services with Android--
that's where you're going
to find those.
TREVOR JOHNS: All right.
So moving on to the next
question then.
X asks, "whereabout in the
source code can I find the 4.1
LockScreen?
The use case is to borrow the
layout, aesthetics, assets, of
the unlock ring." So this is
another one of those questions
that came in right before the
show, so we haven't had a
chance to look it up yet.
That being said, I want to
say that there's just--
there's a package called
LockScreen?
ALEX LUCAS: I think so.
TREVOR JOHNS: It might
be a little off.
If you go to source.android.com,
you can go
to the package viewer
and find--
and just search the page for
lock, and it'll come up.
I know it's in there but I
can't remember the exact
package name off the
top of my head.
I can try and research it during
the next question.
ALEX LUCAS: If you have the
Android source downloaded
already, I would say just grep
the source for LockScreen.
It'll be probably capital S--
or capital L capital S. But I
don't know the package off the
top of my head.
We'd have to look that up.
TREVOR JOHNS: All right.
So let's go hit the
to next question.
Alex, do you want to
take this one?
ALEX LUCAS: Sure.
"What is the best view
to use to display an
option between two items?
I want the user to be able to
select between one way and
round trip.
The available options
don't seem to
fit well in my opinion.
What would you suggest?"
TREVOR JOHNS: All right.
So you just want to go and
have an option chooser
basically, like a
radio button?
ALEX LUCAS: Just to select
between two.
So I guess the--
what are the options
we have right now?
We have the spinner, which
is a drop-down.
And we have radio buttons.
We also have, I guess, tabs,
depending on how you would--
if it would make sense in
the context of your app.
TREVOR JOHNS: Or you could put
two buttons side by side and
make them stay pressed.
ALEX LUCAS: Or you can have
one button that's a toggle
button that just changes the
label or whatever action it's
going to perform.
It's really difficult
to say best one to
use, because we have--
I mean, we just iterated
over most of them.
There are several options,
and it very
much depends on context.
So being able to say--
OK, so to choose between one-way
and round trip, I
assume, means something along
the lines of buying airline
tickets via an Android app
or something like that.
There I would probably go with
a drop-down so you don't take
up too much of the screen.
But it really is context
dependent.
TREVOR JOHNS: OK, I think--
I mean, I think that's pretty
much all the options I can
think of off the
top of my head.
I mean, it's tough to say
without actually seeing what
your application's doing.
We can go ahead and give you
lots of very, very general
advice, but a screenshot would
help immensely here.
So if you happen to be watching
live, feel free to
hop on Google+, give us a little
bit more background
about what you're doing, and
we can go ahead and try and
get you some more tailored
advice to your app.
Failing that, there's also the
Friday App Clinic, where you
can go and get advice from--
I believe Reto and Ian are
hosting that right now.
ALEX LUCAS: Reto and Ian.
TREVOR JOHNS: And then also
there's the UI Show, too.
ALEX LUCAS: What day
is the UI Show?
TREVOR JOHNS: Monday.
ALEX LUCAS: Monday.
Oh, OK.
Monday's good.
DAN: Actually, it's Tuesday.
TREVOR JOHNS: Tuesday.
ALEX LUCAS: Tuesday.
All right. it's Tuesday now.
TREVOR JOHNS: I think it's
probably always been Tuesday.
ALEX LUCAS: I would say also,
one thing to keep in mind for
the Friday App Clinic, the way
that works is you submit your
app and usually you submit
a link to on market--
or, sorry, on Google
Play Market.
So if the app isn't developed
yet, then that wouldn't be the
place for it.
In that case, you'd probably
want to send a couple
screenshots to the UI
review on Tuesday.
But, yeah, I would say those
are options for followup.
But based on what I can see of
the one way versus round trip,
it seems like drop-down
would be--
it would not be a bad choice.
I don't know about
best choice.
I can't say without looking
at you application.
TREVOR JOHNS: Right.
I'm just in here trying
to find that
LockScreen package here.
But no, I think that's
a good answer.
Without seeing the app,
I think we've said
everything we can.
But again, if you're watching
live, we'd love to get some
more details and give you some
more tailored device.
So let's move on to
the next question.
Joe from Maine asks, "I am
sendOrderedbroadcasting--"
wow, it's a verb now.
ALEX LUCAS: Yeah.
TREVOR JOHNS: "I am
sendOrderedbroadcasting
ACTION_MEDIA_BUTTONS--
or button intents to
MEDIA_BUTTON_PLAY_PAUSE--" oh,
I think this is the same
question we got-- "to mimic a
Bluetooth headset button push.
In Android 4 and above, only
Play Music responds, but
pre-4.0, the current music
playing app would respond.
What changed in Android 4?"
I think our answer here is
the same as last time.
We got this question right
before the show, so we don't
know without actually digging
through the source, which it
takes us more than 10 minutes,
especially as we are prepping
for the show.
So definitely a good question.
I'd love to get you an answer.
We just didn't have enough time
to answer it because this
question came in late.
We'll try and get you an answer
by next week's broadcast.
All right.
And this is actually probably
a good time to remind anyone
who is watching live,
feel free to join
us on Google+ Hangouts.
I assume that Dan over here in
the corner is monitoring that.
So if anybody does want to go
and ask a question, just I
guess either speak up or--
you are watching the Hangout,
right, Dan?
DAN: I am watching both.
TREVOR JOHNS: OK, Excellent.
Yeah, there's a tech there
in the corner.
Yeah, so if you do have a
question, just wave your hand,
type something in the
chat, speak up.
We'll try and get you
on there live.
If you don't have a microphone,
you can also go
ahead and type your questions to
us in Hangout chat, and we
can read them out.
We'd love to get
live questions.
Go easy on us.
We can only do so much without
actually having time to
research stuff.
But again, questions like that
last one on UI, excellent
things that we'd love to discuss
live if anyone does
want to go over any of that.
So let's see here.
This question.
Daniel says, "I understood you
wanted to look into last
week's issue after the show--
Edit Text and onPause.
Any news on that one?" I
don't think we have a--
that's the--
Is that the one that has to do
with the support library?
ALEX LUCAS: Oh, that's the one
where the value of the text
box would change when you
rotated the device.
TREVOR JOHNS: OK.
ALEX LUCAS: So it was
pre-populated with Hello
World, and you typed, zzz, and
the value is helloworldzzz.
Then you rotated the device.
The new value would
just be zzz.
TREVOR JOHNS: OK, that one.
ALEX LUCAS: And it was a--
it's an interesting quirk.
We haven't actually had
time to determine
the cause of that.
But I will hopefully have
time to dig into that.
TREVOR JOHNS: Yeah.
We should get you an answer
on that one by
the end of the day.
ALEX LUCAS: Yeah.
TREVOR JOHNS: All right.
DAN: We actually have
a screenshot for the
reservation--
TREVOR JOHNS: Oh, excellent.
ALEX LUCAS: Awesome.
TREVOR JOHNS: Are you able
to put that up some way?
DAN: No, but you can just
take a look over my
shoulder right here.
ALEX LUCAS: OK, so there's
two buttons.
Is there any way for you to
throw that into the Hangout so
that we're not just a bunch
of people staring
off-screen into space?
DAN: Um, I have--
TREVOR JOHNS: You could load
it on the Hangout computer.
DAN: Yeah, I can put
it on the Hangout
computer if you guys want.
TREVOR JOHNS: All right,
yeah, let's do that.
ALEX LUCAS: Sure, yeah.
TREVOR JOHNS: So we'll get back
to that in a second while
Dan goes and makes that
magically work for us.
All right.
So Viti asks, "could somebody
look at this issue on the
Android bug tracker regarding
the broken clipboard on
Samsung's Galaxy S3?"
So I did take a look at this.
And so the issue, in particular,
here is whenever
the user copies data into the
clipboard on that particular
phone, there's a crash.
And that's not really a
compatibility issue per se.
I mean, the API is still--
the API hasn't changed any.
It's more just an issue of
general system stability as
far as I can tell.
ALEX LUCAS: Yeah.
TREVOR JOHNS: And I'm not sure
where exactly-- whether or not
that's an issue because of a
modification that Samsung's
made or if it's a problem
in the framework code.
That said, since it is a Samsung
device this only
happening on, my suspicion is
that there's some interaction
with one of Samsung's
modifications
or a driver or something.
I think this is a question that
we have to send over to
Samsung and they'll
have to address.
It's really outside of our
hands in that case.
If it was a compatibility issue,
we could update the
compatibility test suite.
This is just more an issue of
the system is having some
problem with the clipboard.
So definitely a bug we'd like
to look into, but it's one
that Samsung's going to be
responsible for fixing.
So that being said, now that you
pointed it out, I'll make
sure that somebody at Samsung
does see that.
So let's move onto the
next question.
I think Dan's still working
on that screenshot.
ALEX LUCAS: "When a user touches
a listview item, I'd
would like to hang a view off of
the bottom of the listview
item such that it overlaps
the next listview item.
Do you think that this
is possible?
And off the top of your head,
any ideas on how you would do
it?" That's tricky.
So I don't know if it
would necessarily
be possible to alter--
basically, you would have to
alter the z-value so it would
sort of hang over the
next listview.
TREVOR JOHNS: Yeah, I don't
think-- you wouldn't be able
to do it as a part
of the listview.
It'd have to be another view
that you stack on top.
And in order to do that, you'd
have to go and compute where
the item is on your screen
and precisely
position a window there.
It's sort of painful.
I think it's totally possible.
Just go and create a new view.
Like Alex said, you're going to
want to make sure that it's
in front of everything else
and then just set the x,
y-coordinates.
That said, I think an easier
option would just be to go and
make you listview item
just a little bigger.
ALEX LUCAS: Yeah, that's
what I would do.
You would still have the
effect of pushing
it out of the way.
TREVOR JOHNS: Yeah, it's
not going to overlap.
But it's going to slide
the options underneath
it out of the way.
ALEX LUCAS: And if you really
wanted to, you could also
maybe alter the brightness of
the one below it and above so
that the others around
it kind of fade out.
TREVOR JOHNS: Or the other thing
you could do, actually,
is just insert another listview
item underneath it.
ALEX LUCAS: Yeah, you
could also do that.
TREVOR JOHNS: In either case,
I'd make sure you take
advantage of the animation
framework.
There's a flag you can set on
the listview to go and make
things nicely animate
in and out.
And that'll get you some nice
eye candy to go along with
this effect.
ALEX LUCAS: Right.
If you're in the Hangout, I'd
be curious why you're trying
to do this.
It's not really a behavior that
is typical of a listview,
and it might be kind
of jarring.
Dan's showing us pictures-- or
a video feed of ourselves,
staring into the abyss.
Anyway, it's not something
that's expected, and I'd be
curious what the goal
of that is.
If it's just to command
attention for one listview
item or to indicate it as
selected, or something like
that, there are other ways to
accomplish that that will
require less coding
on your part.
So if--
David from Oakland, if you're
in the Hangout or watching
online, just pop into the
Hangout and give us a little
bit more context.
And we could probably
answer your question
a little bit better.
TREVOR JOHNS: All right.
Dan, do you have that screenshot
for us ready?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
TREVOR JOHNS: OK, so are you
able put that up live?
DAN: Not right at this minute.
TREVOR JOHNS: OK.
DAN: I'm still fixing
some stuff up.
TREVOR JOHNS: We'll wait till
you have that live then.
I want to make sure our viewers
can see what we're
looking at.
It's a lot more interesting
that way.
ALEX LUCAS: Otherwise, we're
just staring at a box.
TREVOR JOHNS: Yeah.
All right.
Let's move one to the
next question then.
And this might actually be the
last recorded question.
So Skate Benji from Italy asks,
"how do I get only the
contacts from the phone, not
Facebook contacts or Gmail
contacts?" I don't think
this is so--
I'm curious if this
is a developer
question or a user question.
Well, let's take the user
question first.
If you're in the contacts app,
you can-- on the latest
version of Android anyway, you
can go to the-- actually I
think-- yeah, in the latest
version you go to the menu.
In old versions, you click on
the Menu button, and there's a
Display Options command.
Let me pull it up,
actually, here.
I'll get you the exact value.
But you can go ahead
and click on that.
And it'll let you pick which
contact sources you want to go
and sort, so it's basically
a filter.
So let's see here.
ALEX LUCAS: And then basically
it gives you the option of
only displaying contacts with
phone numbers attached.
TREVOR JOHNS: Right.
TREVOR JOHNS: So as a user,
that's how you would do it.
TREVOR JOHNS: Actually, it's
called Contacts Display now.
I think it used to be called
Display Options before.
And so I have a thing that says
All Contacts, or Google,
and they list all my
Google accounts.
Or I can pick Google+ if I want
to see my contacts from
my Google+ circles.
If I had Skype installed, it
would show my Skype contacts.
And then there's a customized
option if you want to go and
get more specific.
It only selects certain groups,
things like that.
So that's how the People app,
or what used to be known as
the Contacts app, handles it.
On the API if you want to do
this, the way this works for
each, if I remember the contacts
schema correctly, for
each contact or each person,
you'll have a overarching
contact entry.
And then linked to that, you'll
have an entry from each
of the different content
providers on your system.
So you can go ahead and just
construct a SQL query that
only gets contacts from the
package name that you desire.
So if you--
com.Google will show you all
the contacts from Google
sources, for example.
Or com.Skype would show you
your Skype contacts.
And it's really just a matter
of selecting or adding a SQL
where clause to only select
that packaging.
ALEX LUCAS: Yeah.
I don't know what the
package name off the
top of my head is.
I think it's called com.Google
because of--
TREVOR JOHNS: For Contacts?
For Google Contacts?
Yeah, for Google Contacts,
it's com.Google.
ALEX LUCAS: OK.
But you explicitly say not
Gmail contacts, which I'm
assuming you don't want everyone
in your buddy list
because you don't have
their phone numbers.
So I think it would actually be
a two-part process, where
you search on the account
type being com.Google.
And second of all, you would
filter on making sure that the
phone number is not-- no
one actually has a
value in that field.
TREVOR JOHNS: Yeah.
I'd be a little careful
about this.
Because some phones will let
you pick whether or not you
want to save the contact
to the SIM card
or to Google Contacts.
That being said, most
of the Google--
the Nexus devices will only
save contacts to Google
Contacts, at least for new
contacts that you create
unless you have some other
contact provider
installed, of course.
It is modular.
But the default behavior is only
to use Google Contacts.
And the reason we do that is
because we want to go and make
sure everything is synced
to the cloud.
It gives users a really nice
experience, right?
Whatever new phone
you get, all your
contacts are right there.
So if you decide that you want
to filter out Gmail contacts,
you might be filtering out every
single contact the user
has on their phone.
So I think really if you do
want to add some filtering
here, I think it would be wise
to go and mimic the behavior
of the People app and give
the user a choice.
Which contact sources do
they want to display?
Rather than just saying I only
want to show contacts that are
on the SIM card.
Because, actually, I'd say on
most devices out there, that's
going to get into trouble, and
you're going to filter out
most contacts.
ALEX LUCAS: Yeah.
TREVOR JOHNS: All right.
Any luck, Dan?
DAN: Yep.
I'm good.
Give me one second, I'll put it
up onscreen and our viewers
can take a look.
ALEX LUCAS: OK.
DAN: Here we go, guys.
ALEX LUCAS: So we're
going to be the--
we're bringing UI review
to Wednesday right now.
TREVOR JOHNS: It's true.
ALEX LUCAS: OK.
So--
TREVOR JOHNS: In this case,
there's a spinner on top that
says one way.
And then underneath
that, what's the
text under there say?
DAN: It says "to the airport."
TREVOR JOHNS: Ah.
And then there's a
button that says?
DAN:"Next screen, choose
flight time."
TREVOR JOHNS: OK, gotcha.
So it's like a, say, direction
to the airport app, I imagine.
ALEX LUCAS: OK.
TREVOR JOHNS: Yeah so, first
thing I'd do here-- that
spinner's actually pretty bad.
I'm not a fan of that spinner.
I think your best
option here is--
look at the way Google
Maps does it, right?
You have buttons there for
one way or round trip.
Yeah, I wouldn't use
a tab or use a--
what's it called?
ALEX LUCAS: Radio buttons?
TREVOR JOHNS: Radio buttons
would work.
ViewPager is a nice thing.
Tabs and ViewPagers I'd
leave off the table.
I think that's even more
heavy-handed than the spinner
is right now.
ALEX LUCAS: Tabs and ViewPagers
should only really
be used when each option would
then change the entire UI in
terms of what other options
you were presenting.
TREVOR JOHNS: Yeah.
Now the spinner that you have
right now isn't terribly bad.
The problem is it's
just too wide.
You're using up the entire
width of your page.
But even then, let's say we do
make it smaller and make
things a little more
streamlined.
The problem you're going to
run into here is that it's
multiple clicks to pick what
type of transportation you
want, right?
It's at least two clicks,
actually almost-- it's
exclusively two clicks.
You're going to click on the
spinner, and you're going to
click on the other option.
And you really just don't have
enough choices here to go and
justify the overhead
of a full spinner.
It's really just, option
one, option two.
And so this is where radio
buttons or a toggle switch,
which you could implement just
as two buttons side by side,
would really come in handy.
ALEX LUCAS: Yeah.
TREVOR JOHNS: Yeah.
I think this is definitely a
good one to bring up as an
example on Roman's show.
Too.
But I think that pretty much
answers the question of what's
the best way to do this.
If you do have any more
questions, again, feel free to
pop on to Hangout.
If anybody on Hangout right now
has any questions, I think
now's the time to speak up.
We are at the end of
our pre-submitted
questions for the day.
So if nobody else has
any questions--
anybody signing on there?
Nope.
All right.
DAN: We actually have one
unrelated question.
TREVOR JOHNS: Oh.
Sure, let's take it.
DAN: "Where's the tortoise?"
Which is, I guess, a reference
to "Doctor Who."
TREVOR JOHNS: Yeah, well,
our tortoise is--
ALEX LUCAS: Where
is our tortoise?
TREVOR JOHNS: It's
up on the shelf
DAN: Yeah, it's-- so the answer
is it's still there.
TREVOR JOHNS: It's still there,
just right off camera.
ALEX LUCAS: It's off
camera, yeah.
TREVOR JOHNS: It's
up and to the--
I guess Alex is on the
right on your screen.
It's up and to the right
behind Alex's head.
And you can still that little
green Android there and the
red Android jelly bean jar
just to the right of it.
It's right next to the
jelly bean jar.
It's still there.
ALEX LUCAS: We had a time
machine question, and we
didn't even have a
tortoise on hand.
TREVOR JOHNS: It's
still broken.
It still doesn't travel
through time.
We still can't answer
those questions that
require time travel.
ALEX LUCAS: It's in the
garage right now.
TREVOR JOHNS: Yeah.
But, no, it's still there.
As soon as we get it fixed,
we'd love to answer your
questions about the future.
But somehow I don't think we
have any Time Lords on staff.
ALEX LUCAS: It's a shame.
TREVOR JOHNS: It is.
ALEX LUCAS: We keep trying to
hire them, but no one ever
takes the gig.
TREVOR JOHNS: Well, we
have trouble getting
in touch with them.
They keep floating around
through time.
ALEX LUCAS: Right.
TREVOR JOHNS: Anyway, I think
that's all the time we have
today for questions given that
we're out of questions.
So if you do have any questions
for next week's
show, be sure to hop onto Google
Moderator and submit
them ahead of time.
The earlier you submit
them, the better
answers we can give you.
We usually reset Moderator
about an hour or two
after the show ends.
So if you're watching this
pre-recor-- or if you're
watching this live,
wait a little bit.
If you're watching the recorded
version, it's
probably already up right now.
You can access the Moderator
page by going to either our
Plus page--
developer.android.com/plus.
or searching for Google
Developers Live and accessing
our page from the Google
Developer Live homepage.
So with that said, I think
it's time to say
goodbye for this week.
ALEX LUCAS: Yep.
Goodbye for this week.
TREVOR JOHNS: Yep, all right.
And again, we're every
Wednesday, 2:00 PM Pacific.
Send us your Android questions,
and we'll answer
them for you.
All right, see you everyone.
ALEX LUCAS: Bye, guys.